[Applaudissements]
tous les meilleurs soir dans le prime
des quatre tiers à aller jean luc
lemoine à un moment où vous avez parlé
de votre disparition pendant le prime de
la vérité vous souvenez disparu pour
aller voir ce qu'on allait voir gilles
verdez sait pas trop ce que vous avez
fait pas on a cru longtemps mais est ce
que vous vous souvenez que pendant ce
prime
il m'avait appelé par erreur oui pendant
votre disparition d'un mais non c'est un
truc énorme appareil à 0 que le
producteur des prime non et donc je
venais que je dois tôt qu'un numéro et
je les connais tous par coeur et c'est
vrai que vous appelez un hic étant bien
qui je peux dire ce coup mais quel
talent fou
voilà les impôts établis avec des mots
je suis en train de chiffrer leurs héros
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vraiment des succès à moi tu veux
dire ça je vous dire mais c'est la
nature si vous n'aimez pas la nature ne
l'est pas les hommes